리딩을 산다고 추천한다면 강남대
성수네 선수랑 지금 강남이랑 가격
차이가 그렇게 많이 안납니다 성수도
많이 올라서 저는
[음악]
일단은 오늘은 어 투자자분들이 많이
질문하는 내용을 가지고 한번 좀 지리
응답하는 시간을 좀 갖도록 하겠습니다
요즘 빌딩 시장이 어떤가요 아 요즘에
빌딩 시장은 최근에 좀 거래량이 많이
상승했어요 최근에 기사도 좀 많이
나갔는데 지금 현장에서도 매각이 좀
많이 되고 있습니다 하반기에도
거래량이 좀 더 상승할 거 같고
그리고 본격적으로 상승하는 거는
금리가 내려가는 시점에 아마 거래량이
완벽하게 회복하긴 좀 어렵겠지만 계속
좀 거래량이 많이 늘어날 것으로 좀
예상이 되고 있습니다 대출은 언제
받으면 좋을까요 대출 같은 경우에는
잘 아시겠지만 연말에 받을수록 대출
조건이 매우 안 좋습니다 보통 은행
같은 경우에는 임대 사업자 대출
한도를 좀 정해 놔요 예를 들어서 뭐
1억이다라고 하면 연말에 갈수록 좀
더 조건이 안 좋아집니다 그리고
또하나 아셔야 될게 전반기 시작할 때
그리고 하반기 시작할 때 대출 조건이
좀 더 좋아요 그러니까 이제 하반기
시작할 때가 보통 이제 7월 달이죠
7월 달 조건이 5월 달이라는 6월
달보다는 대출 조건이 조금 좋은 거
같습니다요 부분 한번 좀 참고해서
보시면 좋을 것 같습니다 앞으로의
금리 전망은 어떻게 될까요 제가 뭐
사실 금리를 알 수는 없지만
작년까지만 해도 어느 정도 올려야
될지 이렇게 상한선이 없었잖아요
지금은 뭔가 언제 내릴지 고민을 좀
하잖아요 원래 연주에서도 뭐 6월
달에 내리려고 했지만 지금 좀 계속
늘어지고 있거든요 그래서 그냥
예상컨데 올해 뭐 한 번 정도 내릴
가능성이 좀 있고 그리고 내년에도 또
내릴 여지가 있기 때문에 그때
코로나처럼 급격하게 내려가진 않을 것
같아요 그래서 어느 정도 금리가
내려가긴 하더라도 좀 어느 적정선은
유지가 될 거 같습니다 예전처럼 그런
불장이 온다 지금 막 예전처럼 뭐
대출 금리가 막 2%대 그 이하로
나온다 그런게 아니라 제가 봤을 때는
한 대출 금리 기준으로 한 3%
대에서 좀 계속 좀 오래 가지 않을까
이렇게 좀 예상하고 있습니다 요즘에
뜨는 상권 있나요 요즘에 가장 뜨는
상권은 성수동이 좀 생각을 합니다
성수동은 지금 임대료 수준뿐만 아니라
거래량도 계속 늘어나고 있고 최고가도
계속 경신하고 있어요 성수동을 좀
유심히 보시면 좋을 거 같고 특히
이제 연무장길이면 연무장길 쪽 그쪽이
좀 많이 오르고 있더라고요 그래서
그쪽이 위주로 좀 보시면 좋을 거
같고 강남구 같은 경우에는 아무래도
압구정 로데오가 좀 많이 거래가 좀
되고 있고 실제로 인대 수준도 많이
올라가고 있습니다 강남구에서는 압구정
데오라 볼 수 있을 것 같고 그리고
이제 산이라고 하면은 다른 지역도
많이 있지만 일단 한남동 한남동
상권이 업그레이드 되고 있어요
거래량도 좀 많이 늘어났고 그리고
거기가 덧붙여서 삼각지역 인근 이제
저희가 용리단길이라고 불리는 그쪽도
거래량이든지 임대료 수준이 계속 좀
높아지고 있습니다 추면 남대 어 저는
일단은 지금이 많이 안 나더라고요
성수 지금 강남이랑 가격 차이가
그렇게 많이 안납니다 성수도 많이
올라서 저는 일단은 첫 번째로 저는
강남을 볼 거 같고요 강남이 이제
우선이고 두 번째로 만약에 본다면 뭐
성수 이렇게 볼 거 같습니다
시드머니가 어느 정도 있어요 팅을 할
수 있을까요 일단 진짜 소액으로도 살
순 있어요 풀 대출 받아서 아니면은
공동담보로 내 집을 같이 제공을 해
가지고 소액 진짜 뭐 5억 뭐 10억
안 되는 돈으로도 살 수 있지만
어찌됐든 뭐 취득세나 뭐 이런 거 다
감안하면 는 저는 고객 분들한테
그래도 현금 한 10억 정도 있으면
서울시에 투자할 수 있다라고 말씀을
좀 드립니다 거래라는 진말 있지만
거래에 좀 줄었는데 요즘엔 꼬마빌딩이
더 잘 나가나요네 그래서 지금
통계자료를 좀 보면은 거래량은
늘었어요 여러분들 아셔야 될게
금액대가 매우 낮아졌어요 다시 바꿔서
얘기하면 금액이 높은 빌딩들은 아직
회복이 잘 안 됐고 거래가 좀 잘 안
돼요 보통 이제 그런 큰 빌딩들은
자산운용사에서 좀 많이
매입하거나 보수적으로 바뀌어 가지고
거래가 좀 잘 안 됩니다 그거와
반해서 100억 미만 50억 미만의
빌딩들은 거래량이 좀 많이
상승했습니다 그래서 이런 것 때문에
전체적인 거래액은 좀 뭐
줄어들었습니다 공동투자 탁 어 저는
공동투자를 접 해 보기도 했고 저도
주변에서 좀 많이 봤지만 저는 권하지
않습니다 사실 가족끼리 투자에도 좀
분쟁이 생기거든요 나중에 분명히
문제가 생겨요 돈이 어찌됐든 걸려
있기 때문에 보통은 공동 투자하면
문제가 분명히 생겨 여서 저희 비사
같은 경우에는 공동 투자를 권하지
않습니다 현금이 10억이 있다면
어디에 선물을 사실 건가요 어 일단
현금 10억으로 제가 말씀드린 뭐
강남이나 성수는 사기 사실 사기가 좀
쉽지 않아요 그래도 강남구에 너무
유명한데 말고 좀 떨어지는 곳에서
그래도 좀 투자할 만한 것들이 좀
있긴 하거든요 그래서 그런 것도 한번
볼 거 같고 성수도 막 연무 장기
이런 매인은 살 수 없겠지만 그쪽 좀
이면이라는 아니면 북성 그런 지역에
있는 빌딩들도 한번 올 거 같고
그나마 이제 좀 금액대 낮은게 거래가
잘되는 곳이 홍대 입구역
근처거울가게 되기 때문에 그쪽
지역으로 좀 많이 보지 않을까 생각을
합니다 일단은 투자자분들이 많이 하는
질문을 가지고 좀 영상을 준비했는데
혹시 만약에 나 이것도 궁금하다고
하시면 댓글 남겨 주시면 어 그에
대한 답변으로 영상을 한번 다시 한번
찍도록 하겠습니다 그래서 오늘 영상
여기까지 하고요
감사합니다 e